aoahau
la BAN lisère de la Villa 100000 bornes
de 5 K L la SC ressemble au Nil où les
chiens ressemblent à des loups il y a
des gamins qui jouent au Bill sur les
trottoir gr de trou meuble qui va quand
jamaisou làb les de Pan là où commen les
ass parfois il a des bagnoles qui CR la
nuit des GIR qui passent dans les a des
lames laiss des traces dans les a du
vagal des illusions
s ça ressemble pas à l'endroit où il
est il a bien été à l'école mais sans se
forcer pour autant il on est l'école et
les héros sont rien devant les vacances
cétent en sous-sol entre quatre murs de
ciment aumé des joints et de l'alcool à
montrer les points et les dents c'était
un drôle de paradis à l'endroit où il a
grandi
mougli il a stické du fourneau dans un
débit de hamburger mais ça la Guéré du
boulot alors il est devenu deur il a
stiqué les Barau de sa cellule pendant
des heures il a connu de vra Salau qui
lui on salopé le cœur c'était un peu sa
faute aussi si sa vie était tout
pour C Ann d' est venu entre S justice C
Ann de soleil perdu pour de trop coute
Bénéfic et puis cette femme est venue là
P se glisse ses mains se sont tendu elle
a appelé son fils d'abord il l'a pas
bien compris et puis un jour il a souris
mou comme ça
elle a sorti de sa musette du rouge du
jaune du bleu du noir elle lui prêté ses
palettes ses pinceau ses regards alors
ass sur sa couchette il la
des avenirs et des fenêtres du vent pour
chasser le
brouillard il a dessiné la sortie et la
peinture la
GU Mouli